it's one of humanity's most ambitious
undertakings
created to extend human exploration to
the farthest reaches of our solar system
the next step in space exploration
isn't generations away it's happening
right now and our destination
that mysterious and desolate world
next door mars
imagine starting life over on that tiny
red dot
over 265 million kilometers away
what would happen if we built a city
on mars would you have to live
underground how many people
would you live with and
what would the martian economy look like
this is what if and here's what would
happen
if we built a city on mars
since 1975 the only things from
earth making claims on mars are robots
and satellites but now
elon musk and his company spacex are
looking to change that story
their goal to create a city with a
government
trade and culture on mars
this plan involves 1 000 spaceships and
even more brave new recruits
by surviving in lower gravity with fewer
people and only limited supplies
living on mars might change how we could
adapt
to dwindling resources on earth
but with so much depending on the early
stages of planning and supply runs
could life on mars be sustainable
every great city starts small whether
you're talking about the little fishing
town of hong kong or
a hut village named rome so
if you want this martian colony to grow
into a thriving city
you're going to need more than a handful
of people
according to the bordeaux institute
nacional polytechnique
you would need at least 110 settlers to
start this adventure
the spacex plan starts with two
spaceships
carrying 100 people each with this
handful of explorers
your city would have just enough people
to build
more habitats and research stations
without
putting your resources in danger if you
run out of food at this stage
that's the end of the experiment the
biggest challenge this city faces
is becoming sustainable without relying
on
regular shipments from earth which will
only come
every few years you see with the
egg-shaped
orbit of mars it takes 687
earth days to make one martian year
supply runs would only launch when earth
and mars align
which happens every two years to cut
down on travel time
between our worlds and after this
nearly eight month long trip there's
still a chance of
losing all those supplies when the
rocket lands
since the gravity on mars is only 3 8
of the pull on earth landing safely on
the surface of mars
would be dangerous and that doesn't take
into account the
amount of dust flying in the air after
all the dust on the moon was bad enough
and it got into crew members eyes and
damaged systems on their spacecraft
but kicking up the dust on mars might be
even
more deadly since each grain is
highly oxidized and electrically charged
but hey you made it to mars safely
now what are you gonna eat
the chlorinated soils on mars are toxic
and if you ingested them with your food
you might damage your
thyroid gland so that means farming is
out
outdoor farming at least well before you
worry about eating
you'll need to set up protection from
the harsh conditions on mars
with an atmosphere made of 95 percent
carbon dioxide
the air on mars is toxic
and don't forget about the intense
radiation on the surface
with more exposure to radiation and no
breathable air
you won't be able to survive without a
controlled environment
thankfully with the help of those rocks
under your feet you have
all the protection you need just five
meters of the surface
materials on mars called regolith
provides the same amount of shielding
from radiation
as earth's atmosphere this material
would be processed into cement
to create layered walls using robots and
3d printers this material would be a
protective shell
and underneath that shell dome science
facilities
living spaces and all your home comforts
connected by tubes these domes would
provide you
shelter from the raging dust storms
outside
which might last for months even with
this technology
elon musk claims it could take up to 10
years to establish a colony
but it's during this time that your
quaint martian village
would grow into the first human city
beyond earth
since this world isn't being drilled or
fracked
the power grid on mars can be made
sustainable right from the start
we would set up solar arrays for
electricity
and use natural gases like methane for
engines
our footprint on mars could start low
and
stay that way no matter how many people
live there
and now you better figure out a way to
feed all these people
the low gravity on mars might decrease
your muscle mass
to keep your body healthy you'll need to
provide more protein
you'll have to serve the equivalent of
110 cooked chicken breasts and
660 carrots every day if
one of these domes contained an indoor
farm you could raise the chickens you
need
to feed your city and you would have the
most
nutrient-rich manure available if you
used this manure in the greenhouses
you'd have a way to fertilize your crops
year-round
but how could you irrigate those crops
how would you get water
scientists still debate whether liquid
water exists
below the ice caps on mars but if it
does exist
that fresh water source could be
filtered for the colonists to use for
irrigation
with less gravity on mars pulling water
down into the ground
you would need less water to keep your
plants alive than you would on earth
since
it would stay closer to the surface and
with supplies being transported
only every two years having spring water
available on mars
would change how the city would operate
it would create a government
infrastructure
to distribute and oversee the water
supply
and employ scientists to manage the
filtration needs
now the city has an infrastructure in
place and
jobs to fill so how would you value your
time in terms of cash
how could you pay for products or
services
cash weighs too much to travel with in
outer space and
credit cards would require wi-fi
services
communicating back to earth with a
14-minute gap in communications between
mars and earth you're gonna need
something more locally
based well you might have to use a
cryptocurrency known as
mars coin but you would have need to
have bought it with your earth money
before you boarded the spaceship
while mars coin would only be available
to martians
this money would help build the
government increase
trade and create a standard of living
with society on mars still new
maybe you could trade your services or
learn to barter
goods instead of relying on this cash
system
if we do things right life on mars might
be the model
for future civilizations free from the
constraints of the culture built on
earth
or it could be like every sci-fi movie
ever made
now maybe mars is too tame for your
tastes
if you want to move to mars you want to
push the boundaries of what's possible
so what if you traveled to the hell
planet
well that's a story for another
what if